barack obama a beau être rendu à l'autre
bout du monde
dans ce cas ci au sénégal la sphère
snowdon le suit partout où il va
bombardé de questions au sujet de
l'ancien consultant de la haine et c'est
le président américain a fini par lâcher
ceci je ne vais pas dépêcher des jets de
l'armée de l'air pour aller chercher un
rat que de 29 ans at il dit
pendant ce temps à l'aéroport
sheremetyevo de moscou il y avait foule
à cette porte d'embarquement pour le
départ du vol aeroflot à destination de
cuba
des dizaines de journalistes espérait
enfin voir l'homme le plus recherché de
la planète
espoir déçu l'avion est encore une fois
parti sans lui ce journaliste de la bbc
vient de passer plus de 18h à l'attendre
la warner
personne ne sait où il est dit il
personne ne l'a vu il n'y a pas de
photos pas de vidéo de lui c'est un
mystère total
nous sommes donc également partis à la
recherche de cet homme invisible
supposément caché quelque part dans la
zone de transit de l'aéroport ou mutilés
voir cet employé du stand la hot dog
d'un cône est immédiatement elle a bel
et bien vu mais à la télé pas à
l'aéroport d'edimbourg même son cloche
au niveau de cette boutique à souvenirs
quant à l'employée du capsule hôtel où
ils auraient pu se réfugier elle refuse
maintenant de se faire filmer
elle en a marre de répondre sans
s'indigner la même question de fait il
est possible de vivre dans un terminal
d'aéroport certaines ont fait pendant
plusieurs mois il y à de la nourriture
des toilettes et peint d'endroit pour
dormir mais vivre ici sans se faire
remarquer c'est déjà beaucoup plus
difficile ce journaliste britannique qui
cherche nos donne à l'aéroport depuis
déjà trois jours on est convaincu s'il
est ici c'est derrière des portes closes
oui tu si santos et on voit des portes
écrite fsb qui est le service de
sécurité intérieure russes dit-il alors
il pourrait très bien être là à l'abri
des regards
même si l word claudine est toujours en
liberté washington comme moi se
féliciter d'une chose depuis quatre
jours l'attention du monde entier centré
sur lui et sur les efforts mis en place
pour essayer de le retrouver
est ce qu'un mot temps du même coup
totalement toutes ces révélations
embarrassantes sur l'ampleur du
programme de surveillance de l'année
c'est jean françois bélanger radio
canada à l'aéroport de cheremetievo de
moscou